so i hit 500 subscribers and i wanted to
do a special kind of video i went on
twitter and conducted a poll
i had plenty of good options thankfully
one of them
didn't get any votes but then i
remembered that i'm a dumbass
i put the chaos mode option
i have committed a sin against god
yeah i'm sorry truly i'm very sorry
about the mustache i i look like
some soccer dad who's like hey good job
son
fun fact i just finished my last paper
also merry christmas
right because that's uh that's happening
i think
i have a lot of these don't worry before
i even
get into the dog reveal the pancake
tutorial before i get into any of that
i must say thank you for
um for watching and subscribing it's
very cool by the way
you're getting an exclusive view of my
bookshelf usually i'm sitting down here
like this
i decided i i needed to stand tonight
one second while i retrieve my
my dogs because i feel like you all
deserve that for sticking around
i had to wake i had to wake them up but
this is sedona
she's uh still a little puppy good girl
yeah sorry for the sirens she's very
sleepy
i'm sorry you don't recognize me do you
i
you don't like it sedona our firstborn
and this is
our son buddy who's a little shy and he
doesn't love being picked up
but there he is he's very cute
and very friendly but i'm gonna put him
back because i know he wants to sleep
and i know he probably hates this so
let's get to that pancake tutorial the
secret to pancakes
there is no secret you just followed the
[ __ ] instructions first
you're going to want to get a big bowl
you want to get a big one with as many
numbers on it as possible
you're going to want some hot sauce this
is only if you want a little bit of a
kick to your pancakes get some of that
in there so you're just going to kind of
guesstimate
again that should be fine remember this
is very flammable
stuff so don't snort or inject it or do
anything like that with it you sick
[ __ ] that's probably enough to make 12
or 14
or 25 you're going to need some eggs
i like to use two eggs but you could use
probably three
four five six there's really no limit to
how many eggs you need it's kind of like
a spice that you add on top of your
pancakes so
the trick to cracking eggs is there's
really no trick you just kind of gotta
squeeze as tight as you can
if you get like one or two pieces of
shells that's actually good
so i'm adding some marinara pasta sauce
awesome basically what you need is just
like a metal spoon don't worry about
mixing everything the atoms need to
animate don't break the the yolk try to
show you
gonna [ __ ]
maybe i can still salvage this well i'm
just gonna stir it anyways turn on the
oven
and you can just pour all of it once you
do that then you're pretty much in the
clear
just let that sit for about 10 minutes
basically now you're free to enjoy
pancakes
this is a basically a foolproof method
delicious chocolate chip pancakes
might i add frankly delicious i do want
to thank all of the wonderful people
who have interacted with the channel
lately and the
wonderful other content creators who
i've had the pleasure of getting to know
and befriend there are so many i can't
name
everybody right now a quick reminder
that when i hit 10 000 subscribers
this channel becomes minecraft channel i
don't want you
people to forget that i know it sounds
like a long way i know a lot of people
you like to read but you're going to
have to change your tastes
start watching tommy in it dream george
not found sadness just start watching
those people and get ready for
this to become a minecraft channel but
more seriously 2021 we've got
malazan we've got the dark tower we've
got the wheel of time coming up
thanks for stopping by and watching